- You loved her in Two Broke
Girls and The Neighborhood.
Now she's got a new
podcast called Harmonics
that explores the power
of music and sound.
Let's say a big hello
to Beth Behrs, y'all,
give it up for her!
(upbeat funk music)
(audience applauding)
- How are you?
- I have a, I'm sorry,
I look like a pirate,
or a really cool assassin.
- I love it, I was like, is that?
I thought it was like, I was like,
oh, it's part of her outfit.
You've got the badass-
- I'm totally that cool, yeah.
- The bad boots.
(laughing)
- No, I know, honestly,
I picked these boots
when it was supposed to be another one,
I was like, I'm wearing a patch,
let's wear ones that match.
So, oh, I just rhymed, look at that.
How are you?
- How are you?
Jinx!
(laughing)
- Yeah, I would pinch,
poke and owe you a Coke,
but we can't touch each
other 'cause life sucks.
- [Beth] I know!
- But thank you for being here,
I hear this is like your first time out.
- This is my first time out.
I'm wearing a bra.
- Yeah! (clapping)
- So you know, so thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thanks!
I'm not that big on pants.
I have on cowboy boots again,
although those I've kept with me,
but yeah, I feel excited to
be in human contact with you.
Like, just to see your beautiful
face, and like talk to you.
- Well, some of it.
- Yes! (laughing)
- No, but last time I saw
you, we were folding shirts.
We were doing the Marie Kondo
thing 'cause you love her.
- I love Marie Kondo.
I actually, I did my
whole house, we moved,
so I Marie Kondo'd.
- Oh, I moved recently.
- You did!
- Yes!
- It was something in quarantine, huh?
- Yeah.
- I have to move. (laughs)
- I'm gonna be honest with you.
I, we did it well.
- We did too, everybody was so safe.
We all got tested, yeah,
it was, it was thank,
thank the universe, it was great.
But yeah, we Marie Kondo'd
everything including the garage,
which last time I told you was like-
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was gonna
say, did you get to your garage?
- Yes.
- That seems like a no.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- So, we got to it and
it is better than it was,
but a lot of it sparks
joy for me and my husband,
I guess, the garage,
there's a lot of stuff.
- [Kelly] You're hoarders!
- [Beth] So, I mean,
especially cowboy boots.
There's, that's my new garage Kondo'd.
- [Kelly] Oh, I like your chairs.
- Thank you, do you want them?
They're for sale.
Or actually, you can have 'em for free.
- No, you know, it's so funny.
I have a storage 'cause I
moved into a smaller place
and it's like more charming and kind of-
- Us too!
- Yeah, and love it.
But I was like, I have so much stuff.
- Storage unit.
- It didn't spark joy, so it's just like,
I'm waiting to give it
to someone who needs it.
- It needs that, yeah.
- Yes, but how do you like
your new neighborhood?
See what I did there, with the question?
We're clever.
- You, Kelly, you are so good.
- [Kelly] Still clever in season two!
- Honey, I love you.
Yeah, it's amazing, I mean, we, you know,
we're masked when we go outside,
nobody has brought over
cookies or anything
'cause they can't and we're
not able to go say hi,
but we walk dogs.
There's a lot of dogs in
the neighborhood, right?
- I was about to say, everyone
in my new neighborhood
walks their dogs and
I'm like, am I a jerk?
I just, mine plays in our backyard.
Like, and it's a huge
backyard, so I'm like-
- That's probably like safer in general,
but I think if you're
wearing a mask, and like,
at first, I don't know
if you've noticed this,
but wearing the mask,
you're like meek, I think,
like, I all the time at everybody.
And so, when I'm in the
new neighborhood, you know,
I'm trying to be friendly, but
I forget I have the mask on.
So I'm like smiling, you
know, as big as I can,
but all they're seeing-
- [Kelly] You're like,
are my eyes smiling?
- Yeah, and then the people
have been like walking quickly
away with their dogs, then I
realized, guess what, you guys?
I can just go like this.
- Yeah, exactly.
(laughing)
- I can just use my hands!
- Okay, it's really funny
you said that though,
because this is a thing,
like when I'm in the car,
like, I'm Southern and everyone waves,
like everyone in your car,
like, when you pass someone,
I don't know, you wave.
Especially if you're on
a road and they see you.
No one does that here.
- No, people are terrible.
- No one does that, you wave
and everyone looks at you like,
I don't know you.
(laughs)
And I'm just like, well, you could!
- I'm Kelly Clarkson!
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] We could be friends.
It's so weird, no one does that here.
- We have so much.
- [Kelly] Guys, we have so much in common.
- I know, I know, I, Kelly, I just,
I am so happy to be with you.
- Whenever we're allowed to
hang out, we should hang out.
- We can talk, I know, exactly.
So, I've always been a brown thumb,
so I've never really attempted gardening.
But literally the first thing I did
when we went into lockdown was buy a plant
'cause it just made me feel
like if I can grow something,
the world will like repair itself
and we're gonna be okay.
- Yes.
- So I've gotten really into it.
I'm still a terrible brown
thumb with vegetables.
Everything has died,
(laughing)
but flowers!
Flowers are my jam.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, I love it.
Don't they make you so happy?
- I love it.
It makes me so happy.
I even started, I started
like getting crafty
'cause what else is there to do?
- Yeah.
- I wasn't working.
And we, I started
decorating terracotta pots
and planting plants for like my neighbors
and the postal workers.
I sanitized everything, don't worry,
leaving them outside my door
and gifting these like plants.
And it just-
- It's therapeutic.
- It's therapeutic for me and
to give it to someone else
and go, then someone else
gets a beautiful flower
and it makes them happy and
you're touching the earth,
you're connected to something
bigger than ourselves.
- I agree, I mean, the
new place we moved into,
like, it has like its own,
It's like a secret garden,
the whole backyard.
I didn't have to do anything, it's just,
oh, there's already like
flowers and everything.
It's so great.
- That's so nice.
I actually think I brought you a gift.
- [Kelly] Oh, did you?
- I did.
I'm not sure where it is.
- We'll have to get
that out here next time.
- But-
- Hey, when you say grounding,
are you weird, like, we, oh you did!
- I brought you, I brought you, I guess-
- Are we allowed to touch it?
Or you put it there, okay.
- I can put it on the table.
But I wanted you to have your own flower.
- Hey, did you paint that?
- Something to bring you joy.
I did.
- [Kelly] That's really good!
- It's a whole thing that I learned on,
I think it was Martha Stewart's website.
- Did you tape it?
- Yeah, you tape it and you
do a rubber band around it
however you want it, and then.
- Oh my gosh, that's so cool!
My kids would love to do that.
- It's so, yeah, I'll send
you the link of how to do it.
It's really easy.
- Yeah, oh my gosh.
I'm gonna gift you one
back for your new house.
- (laughs) Thank you!
- This will be for my house.
So, you and I have talked about anxiety.
How have you managed
this during quarantine?
'Cause everybody's kind
of managed it differently.
I've been writing a lot, so.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
For me, you know, I've
always dealt with anxiety.
So, going into lockdown,
even hypochondriac,
which is great for a pandemic
when you're a hypochondriac,
girl!
And old my sort of
techniques of like meditation
and the barn's always
amazing, but it just,
I was still having a lot of
anxiety, if I'm being honest.
And I started listening
to music as sort of,
when I couldn't drop into
meditation, I'd put on a record,
started listening to music
and just wanting to listen all the time.
And I started thinking about
sort of the relationship
between anxiety, mental
health, and creativity
and how healing is creative
and creativity is healing.
And then that led into
this new podcast endeavor
about the power of music.
- It's called Harmonics, right?
- [Beth] Yeah, it's called Harmonics, and-
- [Kelly] So what exactly happens on it?
- So basically, I talk
to like Glennon Doyle,
who wrote "Untamed."
- I love!
- Girl!
- I'm a cheetah!
- So, she's the first episode.
- Oh my gosh!
- And if you listen, she's incredible.
And Brandy Carlisle, who you did that-
- Oh, I love.
- That duet you guys did.
- I have never been more vain,
I've never listened to myself more.
- You two have the best voices of all time
and putting them together.
I've listened, by the way,
I've played that video
over and over again.
I told Brandon, I was like-
- I'm like a million of the views.
- It's on repeat.
But I wanted to ask people
in the music industry,
but also people like Glennon Doyle, women,
how they handle this time, mental health,
what's happening in the
world, the division,
in order to bring people
together, promote love,
and hopefully provide
some sort of healing.
And selfishly, I get
to ask people like you
all the questions I wanna know
about what do you do
for your mental health
on a day when you don't
wanna get out of bed?
- This is an awesome podcast.
- I would love to have you on.
- I would love to come on.
You know who should have too,
another Glennon Doyle type of figure,
is Bernay Brown?
- Oh!
- I love her.
- Her podcast is amazing as well.
- [Kelly] Yes, her Ted talks.
- Her Ted talks too,
everything, yeah, I would love.
I have, I have a dream list.
This is season one.
I have like my dream list, but I-
- That's a really smart
and important thing.
- You know music empowers healing.
I mean, and writing,
have you been writing music or pilots?
- I literally don't know
how anybody goes through
anything horrible or big their life
without having an outlet
like I have with writing.
Like, even if it doesn't
get, I was telling,
I was talking to Gwen the
other day on The Voice,
and I was like, we're
both writing right now
for our next albums, and it's like,
even if no one hears
it, it's so therapeutic,
it's so good for you, just
so that's your outlet.
- And it's almost like, you know,
whether you're religious
or not or spiritual,
whatever you believe,
there's something about that
you're giving that gift of your writing,
even if nobody ever sees it.
- And it's a little like Marie Kondo too,
you're letting it go.
Like, thank you for the
experience, I'm done!
- Yeah, totally!
And I'm terrified for this podcast
because I'm usually like the girl
twerking upside down on television,
and like falling down the stairs.
(laughing)
That's me and everybody knows me!
- There's room for all of it, Beth!
- But I realized is that
like, if I expect my guests
to come on and not talk about, you know,
not just the classic sort
of interview questions,
if I want them to get vulnerable
and honest, then I had to.
And so I've revealed some stuff
and talked really deeply
about my mental health.
But then hearing like that
other musicians that I admire
have panic attacks before
they go on stage, it's like-
- Oh my God, especially musicians, yeah.
- Yes, let's talk through it.
Brandy and I talked about when
she sang for Joni Mitchell
and how, you know-
- I just started sweating
for her right now.
- Did you really?
- Wow.
- But if she can get through
that, I can get through.
You know, there's something
about coming together
and speaking about mental health
openly, which for so long,
especially as women, we're
like, I can toughen up!
You know, I can, I'm gonna
take care of my family,
I'm going to take care
of everybody around me.
- It's all in that book.
- "Untamed," cheetah!
- I know, I know.
- So yeah, it's been amazingly
healing selfishly for me,
but also I hope it helps other people.
- Yeah, I cannot wait to
be on it, first of all,
I would like to and also, I
can't wait to check it out.
It sounds amazing.
- Thank you.